we should talk about the shootout
because it is extraordinary piece of
work the thing that struck me seeing it
on the big screen with this incredible
sound system as well is the the sound of
the guns I mean the reverb and the echo
of those is there like no other
machineries have heard in movies and you
heard millions of machine guns in movies
are those production recordings of the
downtown streets echoing was it done in
post I mean how did you achieve that
those are basically production
recordings we had we had an accelerated
post and so we had one of the most
ambitious mixing schedules I've ever had
where where Chris Jenkins was on one
stage that would work from about I'd
worked there from about 6 o'clock in the
morning until about 2:00 or 3:00 in the
afternoon and then Andy Nelson was
across the street on another stage and
their crew which started about noon or
1:00 o'clock and we would work till 9:00
identical I have a night and we would
definitely work it was very long but the
the the gunshots were there was there
was was so stunning but I think the oil
off was the sound of the purchase and
the actual gunshots in those canyons of
buildings in the way that the sound
reverberating echoed around the
buildings was unique and they were full
load blanks so they were high-powered
blanks and it was frightening you just
stood there and it was a frightening
sound and so we had these really great
production tracks I had said that I
really wanted to use those mostly when I
got on the stage I wound up with a an
elaborate set of cut sound effects which
we then dumped and went back to the some
of the production sound effects and mix
the two together but the the mix is that
these guys did and it it I think's
exquisite I mean it surrounds you and
it's their silences that make you focus
visually into something happening in the
center of the screen because what the
sound does I mean it's a real brilliant
mix these guys did it's a fantastic mix
it's also got you know wonderful
trol of music as well and the music I
have to ask you about the music because
it's it's so rare there are so few
filmmakers are able to take such an
eclectic group of composers and
musicians and make it feel absolutely
cohesive so there's I mean you've got
Brian Eno and they're good all kinds of
anomie and things and then you've got
elliot goldenthal wonderful very
traditional classical sort of school
coming in but it all feels of a piece is
that how did you go about sourcing all
that in the same way that this was the
approach and the approach was was was
all generated kind of from the end of
the film but who the idea was that we
are discreetly immersed into the lifes
of these characters and their lives and
who they are as people make us fill
certain ways and that's going to
determine their outcome then to kind of
max out that polarity from character to
character to character whether it's Al
or Bob or breeding or Val or Sizemore
each one being different generate though
I wanted to go to generate from Dante's
brilliant work in the film a different
lighting style a different way of
shooting certain scenes and then it
argued for very eclectic use of music
whether it's Moby or Brian Eno or Kronos
Quartet and then Elliot Goldenthal Gogol
tall spectacular score and um and the
commonality which puts them together
just is just the emotions of the story
but the idea of it being diverse and
discrete was because everything was
designed to focus towards the conclusion